let's talk about suffering
let's talk a particular experience so
let's talk about me
and the hamster
yeah i just think that
no offense to the hamster probably no
hamsters are listening so uh
so now you're offending hamsters too
maybe there's a hamster that's just
pissed off right sorry there's probably
apologize somebody
on a speaker right now like
listening to this podcast and they
probably have a hamster or a guinea pig
and that hamster is listening
it just doesn't know the english
language or any kind of
uh human interpretable
uh linguistic capabilities to to tell
you to to [ __ ] off it understands
exactly
exactly what's being talked about and uh
can see through us
anyway uh it just feels like a hamster
has less capacity to suffer than me
and maybe a a cockroach or an insect
or maybe a bacteria has less capacity to
suffer
than me
but is that
maybe that's me deluding myself
as to the complexity of my conscious
experience
maybe it's all like it's uh
maybe there is some sense in which i can
suffer more
but to reduce it to something
quantifiable is uh is impossible
yeah i guess i definitely think there's
kinds of suffering that
you have the joy of
being possible for you
that aren't available to a hamster i
don't think
well
can a hamster suffer heartbreak
i don't know can i cockroach up a heart
but certainly there's i mean there's
kinds of um
fear of your own death
um
concern about whether there's a purpose
to existence
these are forms of um
suffering that aren't available to
certain to most non-human animals
whether there's a an overall
scale that we could put physical and
emotional suffering on and um
identify where you are on that scale um
i'm not so sure so it's like
humans have a much bigger menu
of experiences
much bigger
selection in the in one sense at least
so there's like a page that's suffering
so it's this menu of experiences you
know like you have the the omelets and
the breakfast and so on and one of the
pages is suffering it's just we have a
lot compared to uh to a hamster a lot
more
but any one individual thing that we
share with a hamster
that experience
it's difficult to argue that we
experience it deeper than others like
hunger or something like that yeah
physical pain i'm not sure
um but i mean there are kinds of
experiences animals have that we don't
bats echolocate around the world
uh
the philosopher thomas nagle famously
pointed out that you know no matter how
much you understand of the
neurophysiology of bats you'll still not
know what it's like to
squeal and find your way around by
listening to the uh the echoes bounce
off so
yeah i mean i i guess i feel the
intuition that there's um
emotional suffering is i want to say
deeper than physical suffering
i don't know how to make that statement
precise though so one of the ways i
think about i think people think about
consciousness is in connection to
suffering so
let me just ask about suffering because
that's how people think about animals
cruelty to animals or cruelty to living
things
they connect that
to suffering into consciousness i think
there's a sense in which those are two
are deeply connected when people are
are thinking about just
public policy they're thinking about
this it's like philosophy engineering
psychology sociology
uh
political science all of those things
have to do with human suffering and
animal suffering life suffering and
that's connected to consciousness
in a lot of people's minds is it
connected like that for you so
the
the capacity to suffer is it also is it
also somehow like strongly correlated
with
the capacity to experience yeah i would
say
i would say
suffering is a kind of experience and so
you have to be conscious to suffer
um
actually there's so there
as well people taking more unusual views
of consciousness seriously now um
pan psychism is is is one radical
approach another one is what's become
known as
illusionism the view that uh
consciousness at least in the sense that
philosophers think about it doesn't
really exist at all
so yeah my uh
podcast mind chat i i host with a
a committed illusionist so the gimmick
is i think consciousness is everywhere
he thinks it's nowhere
and um
so
so that's one very simple way of
avoiding all these problems right
if consciousness doesn't exist we don't
need to explain it job done
although we might still have to explain
why we seem to be conscious why it's so
hard to get out of the idea that we're
conscious but that
the reason i connect this to what you're
saying is
actually my co-host keith frankish
is a little bit ambivalent on the word
pain he says in some you know in some
sense i believe in pain and in some
sense i don't but another illusion is
francois cameron
has a paper discussing
um
how we think about morality given his
view that pain in the way we normally
think about it just does not exist he
thinks it's an illusion the brain tricks
us into thinking we feel pain but we
don't and
how we should think about morality in
the light of that
you